[Musique]
non mais alors le béotien vous savez ça
le pacte productif c'est pareil c'est
comme les pin's un million d'emplois ça
va finir dans un carton on n'entendra
plus parler
il y a c'est à dire que oui avec
quelques milliards pour les amis au
passage ça c'est la façon dont ça
fonctionne il n'y a pas de plan en fait
pour l'industrie en france il n'y en a
jamais eu à vrai dire il ya un plan par
contre c'est pour effacer et et enlever
le monde ouvrier des radars parce que
derrière
depuis toujours le monde ouvrier celle
d'angers en politique c'est le monde
syndical c'est le monde n'est pas
d'accord avec les règles des riches et
et ça se voit et c'est devenu pourquoi
aujourd'hui il ya cette ce désamour
aussi de l'industrie c'est que pendant
des années on dit que ce n'était pas une
filière s'étaient pas un emploi c'était
un ouvrage vous vous étiez mauvais à
l'école et ben se faisait une formation
s'était pas quelque chose qui était une
carrière en allemagne s'est encore une
carrière c'est une façon d'entrer dans
le monde du travail et c'est même les
patrons allemands la différence
peut-être que les industries étrangères
marche mieux parce que le patron comment
sur la chaîne de montage
il sait de quoi il parle nous en france
on a des énarques après
[Musique]